if you lived in ancient Greece and were
unable to pay your debts the system came
down pretty hard your creditor could put
you and your family into debt bondage
and force you to work however he saw fit
until your debts were paid off
or you die today thankfully in the vast
majority of the world debt slavery is a
figure of speech as opposed to well real
slavery but the stress caused by
mounting debt can still feel like you're
dragging along a ball and chain massive
medical bills spiraling credit cards out
of control student loans can make the
strongest among us weak at the knees
some magic phrase you could just shout
to make it all disappear
I declare bankruptcy as you know and
Michael Scott quickly learns bankruptcy
isn't just a word you declare and your
debts disappear it's a complicated legal
status that is designed to provide
relief to those who are financially
insolvent
if you've cut your expenses down to a
bare-bones lifestyle and still can't
make minimum payments on your loans it
might be time to think about bankruptcy
that relief can seem like a life
preserver when you're caught in a rising
sea of debts but how does bankruptcy
work what are the risks and can it
really make all of your problems
disappear in the United States there are
multiple forms of bankruptcy you can
declare for debt relief there's
bankruptcy for businesses farmers even
municipalities but the most common forms
of personal bankruptcy you'll hear
people talk about are chapter 7 and
chapter 13 the first thing you need to
know is that believe it or not it
actually costs money to file for
bankruptcy three hundred and thirty five
dollars in fact to file for a chapter
seven and three hundred and ten dollars
for a chapter 13 if you choose to hire a
bankruptcy lawyer you will also be
responsible for paying the lawyers fees
which will likely be somewhere between
fifteen hundred and four thousand
dollars depending on which kind you file
for and the complexity of the case
chapter seven bankruptcy is a
liquidation bankruptcy where non-exempt
property is sold and you
to pay off your debt it's generally
meant for people with limited incomes
who do not have the ability to pay back
all or some portion of their debts but
the government doesn't just allow anyone
to file for it first you must pass the
chapter seven means test the easiest way
to pass is if your annual income is
below your state's median this number
usually falls between 40 and $70,000
again depending on your state you can
find the specifics for each state here
if your income isn't low enough you
might still be able to pass the test by
proving you don't have a lot of
disposable income to find out if you
pass either of these tests you can
simply fill out government forms 122 a
one and two if you qualify the court
will decide what is up for grabs to sell
off but States usually have a list of
personal property exemptions such as a
basic vehicle some equity in your home
even cash you've gotten your bank
accounts and retirement savings so you
won't end up living on the street or
without transportation if you're married
and filing together that can typically
double the value of exemptions but there
is definitely downsides you won't be
allowed to use credit cards for quite a
while maybe years and those student
loans you hate yeah the lenders will
have to stop harassing you with calls
but they're not going anywhere
unfortunately student loans are not
eligible for forgiveness if you can't
meet the requirements of chapter 7 you
might want to check out chapter 13 also
known as reorganization bankruptcy your
property is not sold when you file but
you will be required to complete a three
to five year court-mandated payment plan
if you play by the courts rules and
don't miss a payment any unsecured debts
that remain after that time period like
credit cards and medical bills may be
discharged or forgiven to be eligible
you have to have regular income
unsecured debts under three hundred
ninety four thousand seven hundred
twenty-five dollars and secured debts
under 1 million one hundred and eighty
four thousand two hundred dollars but as
with chapter seven even if you
successfully complete the process there
are certain types of debts not eligible
for forgiveness like tax debt child
support and yep once again student
it's also probably no surprise that
bankruptcy can dramatically decrease
your credit score and will stay on your
report for seven to ten years this can
cause issues with potentially finding a
place to rent or even change jobs since
many employers now look at credit
reports but if you were already behind
on your debt payments before you filed
your credit score is most likely already
shot and it won't make it that much
worse and don't despair bad credit
scores are like broken bones they're
designed to heal over time assuming you
follow doctor's orders and don't engage
in the behavior that broke it in the
first place keep in mind this bankruptcy
is also going to be on public record
it's not like you'll be forced to wear a
scarlet B on your chest but if the court
decides to take your payments from your
paychecks directly your employer will be
notified as will any co-signers that may
be on your loans then there's one last
thing you'll be required to do before
your debts are discharged you'll have to
attend an approved or spun consumer debt
these tend to focus on financial
education and lessons on budgeting and
are designed to help prevent you filing
for bankruptcy again if there were only
a place to learn these lessons
beforehand bankruptcy is not a simple or
fast process filing and acceptance can
take many months and you have to be 100%
diligent about following every court
order to the letter and paying every
bill you're still on the hook for like
property taxes and student loans if it's
used as a last resort bankruptcy can
offer you the relief you need it might
put you through the wringer but at some
point it will end and you can start over
and that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description if you would like to
support us on patreon if you or someone
you know has gone through personal
bankruptcy what do you wish you had
known beforehand let us know in the
comments
you
[Music]